and we will let our son go
and be with the angels
tragedy after tragedy give him a chance
give him a chance to live
played out through the courts our
beautiful daughter taffeta is not dying
and behind the cases profound questions
about what constitutes a life worth
living and how and who should decide
when it's over
these points are
to the parents
to decide what is the best sense for
their child
two-year-old elta died after her parents
lost a legal fight to stop the removal
of life support arguing it was against
their religious beliefs her father wants
a law change he's been watching archie's
case
i'm following it from the beginning when
i saw it online
and
i can't
i can't understand it i can't understand
the system i can't understand it
they're just helpless parents are
helpless
[Music]
there can be an insurmountable gulf
between both sides over the right to
life with third-party involvement often
religious groups criticized for
prolonging a painful process
families who are desperate will reach
out to anybody who will tell them things
that they might wish to hear
and sometimes that can include people
who may have
different agendas they may have
different
political or other views that have a
reason to wish to tell the parents
things that
that may not be accurate
the case of tafida rakhib whose parents
won their battle taking her to italy for
treatment has given families hope but
hers is the exception the government's
considering an inquiry into different
ways of handling cases like independent
mediation
a way if possible
of learning from
those where
the parents have been able
to
work with the clinicians
for
the best outcome that they all agree for
their child without getting caught in an
adversarial situation
there may never be a bridgeable gap over
who should decide what's in the best
interests of a child and the fundamental
question over life or death adele
robinson sky news